what would you have me do with him I
swore I would kill him if he ever
returned whomever Ser Jorah was when he
started informing on you he is no longer
that man I can't remember ever seeing a
sane man has devoted to anything as he
is to serving you and yet he did betray
you but you cannot have him by your side
when you do two terrible children of
cute terrible fathers I'm terrible
instead of abolishing slavery overnight
we will give you seven years to end the
practice you promised the slavers that
could keep slavery for a short time
seven years is not a short time for a
slave you will not use them they will
use you that is what they do the masters
have come for their property
despite appearances I think you'll find
the cities on the rock the cities on the
rise marine is strong Commerce has
returned to the markets the people are
behind you
well not all the people of course the
Dornish will lay siege to the capital
alongside the Tyrell Army two great
kingdoms united against Cersei so your
master plan is to use our armies I came
down here to brood over my failure to
predict the Greyjoy attack you're making
it difficult you look a lot better
brooding than I do
you make me feel like I'm failing at
brooding of a fairy I am born of Dornish
allies were attacked on route 2 door and
two or three ships escaped the rest sunk
or captured Hillary and the sand snakes
dead or captured - the Greyjoy's dead or
captured one of them what is it
we took costly Rock
that's very good to hear
isn't it
you'll want to discuss this amongst
yourselves you'll stay who my allies are
gone commit to the blockade of King's
Landing we have a plan it's still the
right plan the right plan your strategy
has lost us dawn the Iron Islands and
the reach if I have underestimated our
enemy my enemies your family you mean
perhaps you don't want to hurt them
after all you will not trade your honour
for your life I respect that perhaps you
could take the black your grace whatever
else he is he is a true soldier you'd be
invaluable at the war you cannot send me
to the war you will have to kill me to
step back and shut your mouth
your grace nothing scrubs bold notions
for any man's head like a few weeks in
the dark sin I meant what I said
says he thinks the army of the Dead is
nothing but a story made up by wet
nurses to frighten children what if we
prove her wrong I don't think she'll
come see the dead at my invitation so
bring the dead to her I thought that was
what we were trying to avoid do you know
what I like about you I honestly don't
you're not a hero oh and I saw hundreds
of arrows miss but any one of them could
have found your heart and ended you've
been thinking about my death quite a bit
haven't you is this one of the items you
discussed with your brother in Kingsland
I'm trying to serve you by planning for
the long term perhaps if you plan for
the short term we wouldn't have lost
Dorne Highgarden you can't win the
throne if you're dead can't break the
wheel if you're dead so what would you
have me do nothing sometimes nothing is
the hardest thing to do you told me to
do nothing before and I listened to you
I'm not doing nothing again and soon the
Lannister army will ride north to join
our cause
I know I know our people who haven't
been friendlies in the past nobody
trusts my sister less than I do believe
me you have every right to be fearful of
my sister no one fears her more than I
do but I promise your visas he told you
her army was coming north to fight for
you you believed her she has something
to live for now I believe she wants to
survive I used to think you were the
cleverest man alive either your new
Circe was lying and let me believe
otherwise you didn't know at all it
makes you either a traitor or a fools of
all not for the first time Circe still
sits on the throne if you can't help me
take it back
I'll find another hand who can I suspect
one of you will be wearing this before
it's all over your grace I know my
brother like you knew your sister
perhaps he trusts his little brother to
defend him right up to the moment he
slits my throat
you could temper her worst impulses as
you have you've always loved your
children more than yourself if not for
yourself then for your child
Raina's over but that doesn't mean your
life has to end doesn't mean your baby
has to die
[Music]
[Music]